what makes your company different I'm a
big believer that to have success as an
entrepreneur you need to do something to
stand out you need to have a mission
that you're on a purpose that you're
living that will attract great customers
to you great employees to you great
media to you great suppliers to you you
have to have something different because
there's so much competition out there
consumers and customers have so many
options to go to why should they choose
you and a lot of it comes down to
picking one word that you can stand for
that you believe in that explains what
makes you different what mission you're
on pick one word and let that be a
magnet for you I got a question from one
of my youtube viewers love you guys Lily
who are in the SE I think what makes me
outstandingly different is my
personality I'm a giving person and not
many are like this nowadays everyone is
all for themselves replying back to
comment what makes me different you can
build a company Lily around giving and
you can still be a highly profitable
company even though you're giving a lot
and what you want to do is build that
into your culture so your customers know
that you're a giving company and
potential employees know that you're a
giving company somebody like me I love
to work with so I don't know what your
company's actually sells but if you sell
shoes I'd love to work with a company
that sells shoes that is really giving
or I'd love to work with a website
development company that's really giving
I like I like working with people who
are giving that's what's different so
built that into your culture it
immediately separates you from everybody
else if you're selling to your real
estate agent okay most people think real
estate agents are all in it for
themselves or they're egomaniacs put in
their faces up on all on every sign
right you may not like your real estate
agent what real estate agent is known as
the giving agent now you have something
to stand out on now you have something
that is different than every other real
estate agent you're not the one who's
saying I'm in the top 1% sold for this
neighborhood right that's B
people don't care about that everybody
says the same thing nobody says they're
the giving real-estate agent and it's
not just a marketing thing you have to
live it right what does that mean to be
the giving real-estate agent
what does that mean to you and it's how
you treat your clients it's how you
determine your products and your
services it's how you bring on new
people to your team it's how you bring
on customers you want customers who love
the idea of giving as well this is so
important for you to figure out if
everybody watching you gotta figure this
out it's your way it's your path to
become successful I'm about believe
right it boozes from everything that I
do I believe in entrepreneurs and it's
so easy for people to spread the message
about my business because I give them a
clear message right if you're a real
estate agent how do I spread the message
about you I can't I'm not gonna tell
friends oh he or she is in the 1% of all
agents in this neighborhood give me
something to talk about
this is it you're the giving real estate
agent so people know that I'm about
belief and that's an easy message to
spread and people either love it or they
don't and that's cool
I'm not here to convince anybody but it
helps people self-identify so it helps
my customer self-identify if you are
company who wants to work with me and
you don't believe in entrepreneurs we're
not gonna have business together
I'm not going to convince you that this
is the right thing to do I don't want to
work with you I don't want to talk to
you because you're not on the same
mission as me and I don't have to sell
you on anything and the companies who do
believe in entrepreneurs they know I'm
the guy to talk to
because I'm spreading this message and
I'm living what I'm preaching same thing
for bringing on employees onto my team
I need people who believe in
entrepreneurs if you don't like
entrepreneurs you're not gonna have fun
on my team you're not gonna be in a good
place you're not gonna enjoy your job
but if you love entrepreneurs and you
believe in them this is the best place
for you and I'm not bringing on people
and convincing them hanging you've got
to love entrepreneurs now this is
something that you come with and fear of
that mindset then you're gonna be great
on this team so I don't know what it is
that you sell and it almost doesn't
matter because you've done the harder
work in understanding that your culture
is all about giving and you apply that
to anything that you're doing okay I'm
about believing if I wasn't helping
entrepreneurs I'd be believing in
somebody else I'd be believing in people
learning how to salsa dance I'd be
believing in learning how to be a piano
player I'd be believing in making chairs
that are amazing whatever it is
believing is part of me I believe in
people and I've applied it to helping
entrepreneurs you're a giving person
apply it to whatever it is that you're
selling and for everybody else watching
figure out what your one word is and
apply that because until you do you're
making it impossible for people to know
where you stand and you're making it
super difficult for people to spread the
message about you and you want to make
it easy for people to talk about you
especially if you're in a competitive
field believe for those you're watching
you like the video give it a thumbs up
let me know what you think you have your
one word put it below - I want to see it
you have a question leave it below make
a beauty reply for you thank you so much
and I'll see you soon